two months before the game came out I
had a conversation with with some of the
board members that guys I think we have
something good here maybe let's try to
already do something with it
and the reaction was like I know it's
your baby calm down
right it seems cool but you know let's
see what people say
[Music]
there's something oddly enticing about a
game within a game it can be a simple
diversion a way to earn some quick
rewards and can even serve the game
world if done correctly I spent hours
playing classic NES and Animal Crossing
and I lied and cheated my way through
dozens of poker tournaments and Red Dead
Redemption when The Witcher 3 released
in May 2015 when was the last thing on
our minds and a huge RPG with dozens of
key characters hundreds of quests and a
story that had been in the works for
almost 10 years
it didn't seem like one would be able to
divert anyone's attention for long
however even as The Witcher 3 launched
to an overwhelming amount of praise for
its core RPG gameplay fans were becoming
engrossed with went soon they were
clamoring for more but the fan favorite
card game almost didn't make it into the
final version of The Witcher 3 fans of
collectible card games themselves
designer Rafal yaki and Damien Monet had
devoted hours to making prototypes of a
card game that could fit into the
Witcher after weeks of work they
realized that the game simply wasn't fun
when it was time to show the managing
director what the team had been up to he
was not impressed he was about to
shutter the card game altogether but in
one last-ditch effort Monier spoke up
Damon had a panic attack I think at that
time and he said no no no we'll do it
and we're late I'm like woah woah what
we'll do the card game we're do it just
believe we already have it it's fine
we'll do it and I was I was completely
really scared at that time and and I'd
almost like he was looking at music nope
you don't you you don't have anything so
but if you really do it's Friday today
so bring a working prototype on Monday
and yeah then we decided that weekend
the duo went straight back to work
yeah Keon Monier didn't have to start
from scratch but they had to rethink a
lot of the core mechanics one of the
biggest challenges was simplifying it
but not to the point where it became too
shallow the team did manage to settle on
something they liked but they would soon
realize that that was only half the
battle
so during the weekend we we actually
settled on a prototype
we actually did it we brought like trump
cards with posters on it and we we just
we just went to Adam and just showed it
to him except yep yep that's cool let's
do that but he didn't give us resources
or any of you just said okay everybody
slammed you know just I don't know how
but just go and do it so we actually
lured other people that we need it in so
he played a scheme because there's a big
corridor in cvpr and we sat down with
Damien and we tried to enjoy playing the
prototype so much that everybody will
hear that we're enjoying oh my god this
amazing game that we came up with Oh
Damon you're having so much fun uh and
it's like we're exaggerating trying to
lure the specific people we needed for
the project for example Travis who is
one of the guy that helped us with car
tags and rules was walking by said oh
what's that
this is something do let's try it out so
so we basically show it to him and said
yeah that's extremely cool good you're
going to make it with us and basically
that's that's how the whole thing
started and obviously when the
contraction and people kind of fell in
love with it internally you know more
people jumped in on board and we may
make it happen we made it happen but
there was like two or three times where
it wasn't a chopping block and was this
close for that being in the game because
you know everybody was slammed anyway
but as The Witcher threes release date
closed in went not only became a sure
thing but the team felt they might be
onto something great something more than
just a mini game players would forget
about after the credits rolled
[Music]
the first day on release I think I've
read obviously all the reviews of the
game a great moment for the studio but I
think at the third or fourth review I've
read one of the pluses was Gwent and I
was yeah I already send it to the board
members I see somebody said Gwent is
great and then a week later people
started to send us emails and messages
and you know basically spamming our
mailboxes with like what are you doing
extended on Gwent and really you know
the fans helped us make this happen
because I already had in a week I
already have hundreds of emails that I
could send you know saying that people
really love it and so I think I made a
presentation within a week from that
point pitched it to the board and they
said okay let's put out the small team
and let's try to figure out what would
have to happen for this to be a
standalone in spite of its popularity
Gwent had some issues if you played went
in The Witcher 3 then you know it was
not particularly balanced the further
along you progressed the better your
cards got and by the end you were
supposed to be unstoppable however this
doesn't quite work for what yaki and
monie a hope to become a standalone
competitive card game well first and
foremost you've learned that people will
break our game fast they will break
anything that we put out there they will
find a way to exploit that easily even
if we do you know hundred people QIS and
you know we have competitive players
playing it
we have PTR's where you know we have the
best players in the world playing the
game before it give one day one kid in
ukranian but he just finds something
that we couldn't that really changed our
perspective of how we should approach
things and I think we're more cautious
and like try to find
the best way to address like more
systemic things rather than jump on like
oh this card is oh people let's draw
let's change it let's change it fast
because then it everybody will be happy
when shaping up to be a great
multiplayer game but what really sets it
apart is a fully fleshed out
single-player campaign although we
haven't seen much of it said that
project red promises an ambitious
role-playing game that will follow in
the footsteps of The Witcher series
doing single prayer content is something
that me personally and a lot of people
on the team felt that and was not done
at card game there are two things that
the single-player campaign hope we will
do one we hope to bring people that
enjoy it which are free playing Quint
and if they want to ignore the
multiplayer stuff slowly find where else
because you know we love The Witcher
wall and girl'd story has ended but
there's so many interesting stories and
characters in this world that we can
talk about and we can tell their stories
and we never actually had a formula to
do so but now we do and that means that
we can go into different times we can
talk about different characters not only
Geralt necessarily and I think that's a
very cool aspect of it and people
hopefully will enjoy that part because
the virtual world is so vast and complex
and we love it and the second thing is
that people that enjoy multiplayer might
find a different pacing for
single-player this may be you know we
see it we see it a lot there's just
people that play Gwent and they never
actually played The Witcher game ever so
we hope that because they like went
maybe they felt they will fell fall in
love with The Witcher world that's our
hope so those two things are quite
important for us and and we try to make
it as something that's really rooted and
connected into the ocean world not dumb
it down
you know have meaningful choices in
there and hopefully people that loved
witcher come back and say this is
amazing and we liked it people that
don't know witcher will fell in love
with
[Music]
The Witcher universe is Gwen's advantage
yaki and the development team don't
intend to make just another CCG riding
on the coattails of hardest stone rather
they want to make a full Witcher game
with all the elements that fans expect
from the series because the last thing
you want to do is for your game to be
generic not memorable and I think
because people that work on our team
when when everybody plays all the time
and they really love this world
they've been either with this world for
for a long time or they're newcomers
that actually joined the team recently
but that's that's something that you
cannot replicate really easy I think
because I hoped people can find and feel
that there is a huge amount of devotion
and love in the game but I think it's
kind of special for Gwent because it's
become it became a thing because people
were passionate about it and that
transfers and that's our obligation to
the players and we just want to make
them happy
[Music]
you